test scores and their outcomes all that
is great but none of it matters if our
children are not completely safe
parents of Clark County students
concerned over the number of weapons
seized from CCSD schools records show
it's a number that's gone up over the
past five years Joshua peguero obtained
records from the district showing
exactly how serious this situation is
Joshua now this graphic behind me shows
the increase 31 guns were seized at
2017-2018 school year the number drops
as students are engaging in distance
learning during the pandemic but so far
in this school year 37 guns have been
taken by school police already eclipsing
the total from last year
unfortunately my youngest my special
needs son he was attacked in September
of 2021 till this day haunts my special
needs son if he hears a loud commotion
fights breaking out my son freaks out
Jessenia Gonzalez has three children
enrolled in the Clark County School
District they've experienced violence in
the classroom to go to Cram Middle
School and want to go to Mojave High
School in both Schools students were
arrested just this month for bringing a
gun there are fights breaking out if
there are weapons in schools the
children are not learning Gonzalez and
these two other moms are joining dads in
schools it's a program that kicked off
this school year where parents partner
with CCSD to volunteer at schools the
motto is prevention through presence my
biggest concern is that one of these
fights would escalate into actual gun
violence or knives they say these issues
affects a child's ability to focus and
learn record shows CCSD police have
seized handguns long rifles and shotguns
this week four students were arrested
for bringing weapons to Mojave and El
Dorado high schools and Escobedo Middle
School it's very concerning that these
kids are bringing guns onto campus it
really shows they're not focusing in on
education anymore they're more afraid
for their security and their welfare I'm
very concerned I know there's plenty of
teachers that are concerned also for
their own safety
now school police have also seized
knives from students the number shows
even in the 20 in the 2019-2020 school
year with in-person learning cut short
94 knives were taken so far this year
it's 138 Kirsten thank you Joshua as
always CCSD encouraging parents to be
aware of what students are taking to
school to secure any weapons they may
have in the home and if you would like
to volunteer with the group dads in
schools that Joshua referenced you can
find a link on our website at inside the
8 News Now app it is available for
download on both Google Play and the App
Store